[Musique] les
gars, préparons-
nous pour aller au lit, est-ce qu'on peut juste
regarder jusqu'au lendemain,
je n'aime pas ça quand vous regardez des
trucs comme ça avant de se coucher, alors allons-
y,
ce n'est pas la vraie maman, ça va si ce n'est pas le cas
[Musique]  ]
réel
croyez-vous au mal quelque chose d'un
autre monde
oui vous n'arrêtez pas le mal
vous ne pouvez que vous en protéger
je m'inquiète pour Dylan
j'ai quelque chose à vous montrer il y a des
références
au bagool dans toutes les cultures
certains croient qu'il a nourri
oh pour  la corruption de l'innocence
il y a toujours trois choses en commun
il y a une famille assassinée
une maison et une forme d'offre
ce qu'elle dit c'est les coordonnées de l'
endroit où une ferme
où toute une famille a été assassinée
personne ne vient jamais
ici c'était terrible ce qui s'est passé
c'est le  les enfants il a les enfants celui-
ci est à moi
ta famille est en danger pourquoi il va nous faire du
mal
je ne laisserai pas
ça arriver  toi avec moi
toi